We're going to talk
a little more about this.
But, basically,
what I just talked about, for example,
whether you're doing the whole histogram
the histogram of the whole image,
which doesn't work very well,
but you could do it.
Or if you build like these orientations
of gradients in each of the quadrants,
you're building a model,
a description of that instance.
By the way, you take each of those four,
those histograms before and
you just string them into one
great big feature vector.
That's your description.
So now what you have to
do is you have train, or
sometimes referred to as learn,
a classifier.
Given a bunch of those feature vectors
describing koalas and given a bunch of
them describing pandas, figure out how
to discriminate one from the other.
So here's the basic description,
all right?
So let's suppose we're trying
to learn cars versus not cars.
So how many classes is that?
>> Two.
>> Sorry, how many classes are that?
How many is that?
It is six.
There are six classes, but
the number of classes is six.
Actually, the number of classes is two.
I don't know.
It's called a binary classifier,
because there are two classes.
So, for example, suppose I have
a little picture here of a car, and
I have to decide, is it a car?
And what do you think,
you think that's a car?
>> Yes.
>> Good, she got it right.
Yes.
It's a car.
Okay?
Now here's another picture.
Taken.
Oh, somewhere in China I think?
I don't remember where.
Sorry.
So, is that a car or not a car?
>> No.
Very good.
What we need are methods of doing that.
Now, there has been a huge
effort in machine learning and
applied to computer vision over
the last really 15, 20 years,
of methods of doing
discriminative classification.
What you see listed here
are a whole bunch of methods,
a couple of references below them
of how to go about doing that.
We're going to talk about three of them.
I've just highlighted them here,
nearest neighbor, SVMs, boosting.
There are others as well.
[COUGH] the general approach, and
there's a huge literature on this now,
especially with these large scale
object recognition competitions, of
what's the best feature vector you can
use, learning different feature vectors,
sparse representations,
a bunch of other things.
And then, given those representations,
what are the methods that you should
use to make the classification?
Here are the three that
we're going to talk about.
If you take more machine learning,
just remember later
you could apply those methods
to those other representations.
Our fundamental assumption
is going to be someone and
hopefully that's somebody
you don't have to pay.
But somebody's going to give you
a database of lots of examples of
the things you want to find and
lots of examples of the things
you don't want to find.
And then you're going to
train the classifier.
Now once you do that, you have to
come up with some way of test,
given some new image.
How do you test it?
So remember we talked about you have
to generate these new candidates and
you have to score them.
So here's the basic idea.
You start off with a window,
and then, and
Kristen is really good at
this animation, right?
And you might take that window
of a particular size, and
you scan it all over.
And what you do is you apply your car,
non-car classifier to every
one of those windows.
And you say do I see any cars?
Do I see any cars?
Not very clever, but
it just works very well.
Right?
Because the classifiers are quick and
they're accurate.
So, as opposed to having a different
way of trying to do detection versus
labeling, I, basically,
do detection by labeling.
There is a problem, of course, though.
I picked a window.
Well, suppose I'm nearer to a car.
Does the picture get,
of the car get bigger or smaller?
That one's an easy one Megan.
If I get car, bigger does,
closer does it look bigger or smaller?
>> Bigger.
>> Bigger, very good.
So what do I have to do?
Well I just have to try bigger windows.
And I slide those all over the place.
And if this feels kind of
date intensive, you're right.
And there's various tricks to doing it.
But that's the general idea is that you
take these different sized windows and
you apply them to different
places in the image.